هل كان الملياردير الامريكي الاشهر بيل
جيتس على علاقه غراميه مع هذه الشبه
الروسيه الصغيره
احدهم نبش في التاريخ واخرج رساله ابتزاز
الكترونيه عمرها ست سنوات
المرسل جفر ابستن انتحر منذ اربع سنوات في
سجنه بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم جنسيه المستقبل
مؤسس مايكروسوفت اسرار جفر ابستن
الملياردير الذي كان مولعا بالقاصرات يبدو
انها لم تدفن معه مازال قادرا على احراج
العديد من المشاهير بعد وفاته وفق صحيفه
وول ستريت جورنال هدد جفري بيل جيتس عبر
البريد الالكتروني بفضح علاقته الغراميه
مع الفتاه الروسيه ميلا انتونوفا والتي
حدثت عام 2010
لعبت انتونوفا مع غيتس لعبه بريج
السنه الماضيه لعبت ضده على نفس الطاوله
في اتحاد لعبه بريدج في واشنطن لم اهزمه
لكنني حاولت ركله
انتقلت انتونوفا للعمل كمهندسه برمجيات في
منطقه بيه وكانت قد اقرت بوجود علاقه وديه
تجمعها
بينما ابقى جيتس الامر سرا ربما خشيه من
زوجته ميلاندا التي انفصلت عنه قبل نحو
عامين
اجتمع وتشارك موائد الطعام مرارا
هذه اللقاءات كانت خطا ولم تسفر عن نتائج
كما وعدنا ولقد اوقفتها تماما وهذا كان
منذ زمن بعيد جدا ولا يوجد شيء جديد حولها
لا احد يعلم ما اخفته تلك اللقاءات ربما
بانتظار منقب اخر يحرج جيتس او ملياردير
اخر اغرته قاصره جفري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات